bon elle a une vie scandaleuse mais
c'est surtout au moment où elle a
commencé à jouer à jouer la comédie ou à
danser qu'elle est devenue un objet de
scandale
oui je sais pas si aujourd'hui ça ferait
autant scandales ont quand même
lcl s'est acoquiné un moment après sa
séparation d'avec woody avec cette
marquise de belbeuf qui était un
personnage étonnant qu'ils étaient sains
qui avait l'air d'un travelo elle
ressemble à philippe noiret physiquement
venue cette barbie et colette quand même
s'est exhibé avec elle a joué une
pantomime sur la scène du moulin rouge
où elles se sont embrassées ça fait un
scandale c'est presque la bataille
d'hernani qu'elle joue est quasiment nul
as est la première actrice qui est
montré ses seins sur une scène sur une
scène est disons et ça fait un tel
scandale que le préfet de marseille de
l'époque a fait interrompre le spectacle
et l'a obligé à se voiler le soleil
il ya eu des articles dans les journaux
ça qu'elle avait forgé lille il ya de
très belles photos super paix mais il a
tout osé c'est ça que j'aime chez set ça
elle a tout osé tout oser et puis elle a
osé d'ailleurs le grand tabou chaque
fois parce qu'avec eux avec de jouer
même si c'est un très grand amour mais
elle a été amoureuse la mort de willy et
je crois que c'est l'homme de la vie de
ceux qui l'ont connu
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer encore
quelques-uns c'est le plum qu'elle a le
plus aimés au monde oui fait dans sa vie
ensuite il ya eu jouvenel avec lequel
elle a eu une relation très sensuelle
très gourmande elle a été très amoureuse
d'un rude jouvenel et surtout elle a été
très amoureuse de son fils bertrand
alors ça c'est une histoire aussi vous
raconter en bus parce que je raconte en
détails parce que bertrand de jouvenel
qui a aujourd'hui 81 ans me la raconter
en dix ans après tout tout le monde est
mort je vais vous le raconter et
maintenant encore il en est très ému
donc il a été le héros du blé en herbe
et non pas le shérif comme on l'a mais
non chérie c'était un jeune fils de
banquier et qui n'avait rien à voir avec
bertrand de jouvenel mais on est il a
été le héros du blé en herbe mais
surtout il recule l'âge de 7 ans il y
avait 16 ans de l'être la rencontre elle
en avait 47 et
devenu l'amant squelette et de son aveu
il ne voyait aucune autre femme
non sans être un temps il a été fou
amoureux de cette femme on essayait ses
parents qui étaient pas content
évidemment ont essayé de lui mettre dans
les pattes toutes les jeunes filles
riches pour pouvait trouver et bertrand
ne voyait qu'elle
alors que quand même c'était une dame
plus que mûre est en plus assez grosse
cet âge là et apparemment elle avait
rien pour séduire elle séduisait ce
garçon qui était d'une beauté totale
je trouve que c'est quand même il faut
quand même le dire parce que quand on
voit des pauvres dames faire des régimes
être complètement effrayé par par leur
aspect physique il faut leur dire que
tout ça n'est pas très important ce qui
est important c'est le charme se charge
lui-même de la conversation la culture
ne se fait pas la part la culture
qu'elle séduise air de l'été je vais pas
par une attraction fresque magique
vous savez que les animaux la suivait
les liens de ces ânes ces amoureux qui a
raconté qu'elle avait une peau qui
sentait l'homme elle avait une peau qui
avait une odeur extraordinaire qui
attirait qui fascinait les gens et elle
est même cause de la rupture des
fiançailles de 10 janam du jeune homme
joue même qu'à ce moment-là 21 22 et un
jour brûler ses parents sont arrivés à
leurs fins ils y ont fait rencontrer une
jeune fille et des fiançailles
officielles ont été décidées et en plus
dans des milieux très bourgeois et de
l'épaule et il est allé voir colette un
matin et il lui dit c'est épouvantable
crtac fiançailles à midi j'ai pas envie
d'y aller et colette lui a répondu mme
annie va pas et il est parti quand même
un peu en traînant les pieds pour aller
se fiancer et colette par la fnac de
plus sa maison a envoyé un petit papier
qui à voleter que bertrand a ramassé et
y avait marqué je t'aime et bertrand
indienne ne me l'avait jamais dit avant
et à ce moment là je veux pas aller
assez hop son repas tillon ça y est
quand même assez extraordinaire sur les
fiançailles vous diront plus active ascq
embarras bien un scandale dans les deux
familles et collègues devaient être très
contente de son coup
bon